red wine is good for your heart okay
actually
this is
the biggest myth of all time
meat is a necessary part of a balanced
diet
this is a controversial one and i love
this topic fruit is as unhealthy as
candy
if it's orange soda and snickers or an
apple
eat the apple hi i'm tamar samuels a
registered dietitian and the co-founder
of coolina health hi i'm vanessa rosetto
and i'm a registered dietitian and
co-founder of kalina health and today we
are debunking 19 diet myths myth number
one
beans are toxic
no beans are not toxic they have fiber
they have protein they come from the
earth i mean tomorrow i think this is
just another way to like vilify carbs i
think maybe people mistake a little bit
of gi discomfort with toxicity beans as
vanessa said are really high in fiber
which is a good thing but a lot of
people don't eat enough fiber and when
you first reintroduce fiber it can cause
a little bit of indigestion some
bloating maybe some gas but that doesn't
mean it's a bad thing it means that you
should probably just start slower with a
smaller portion and build your way up to
you know a full cup of beans okay myth
number two bananas pack the most
potassium potassium is found in pretty
much every fruit and vegetable also
kiwis have the most potassium and that
uh bananas thing is just like a
marketing scheme from the 80s so they
had like the chiquita banana and it was
like get all your potassium from bananas
delicious chiquita bananas are rich in
potassium number three honey and agave
syrup are better than sugar
actually
there's no difference right sugar is
sugar is sugar ultimately the way that
we process all of these simple sugars is
exactly the same in the body although
honey and depending on the type of agave
may have a slightly higher nutrient
profile so it might have a little bit
more minerals than the sugar itself
which has absolutely no vitamins
minerals or phytonutrients myth number
four fat-free foods are always healthy
first of all everybody responds to
different foods differently
fat free foods can be healthy but a lot
of the times they're not healthy often
times when we take away the fat we take
away the ability of the food to make us
feel full and then we also add in things
like sugar to make the food more
palatable to make it taste better which
can actually end up making the food
itself
not healthy at all it's not worth it
just just eat the regular
serving of fat and you'll be better off
myth number five
fruit is as unhealthy as candy
fruit has antioxidants and vitamins and
minerals and fiber which no one gets
enough of so
please eat the fruit like if it's orange
soda and snickers or an apple
eat the apple yes this myth is
especially dangerous
because i think people will equate fruit
in that bad food category and
then avoid it and they're missing out on
a whole set of nutrients and then also
tend to overeat candy so they'll say
something like my doctor said that i
have to be careful with the fruit that
i'm eating because it increases my blood
sugar and then they'll over eat you know
chocolate at night
myth number six breakfast is the most
important meal of the day i think this
myth can be harmful because for people
who have all or nothing thinking they
believe that if they don't get breakfast
right or have a healthy well-balanced
breakfast then the rest of the day is
sort of ruined and they use that as an
excuse for them to not make healthy
choices for the rest of the day the
reality is that every time we eat is an
opportunity for us to take care of
ourselves and eat a nutritious meal if
you do not eat if you spend long periods
of time not eating then your metabolism
doesn't know to do its job even having
like a small piece of fruit and like nut
butter or nuts in the morning is just
like enough to fuel your metabolism and
get yourself going and likely making
sure that you're not gonna overeat at
later meals myth number seven you must
drink eight glasses of water a day you
know there's like these quick and dirty
calculations that dietitians use to
determine how much water someone should
drink and so it's usually
your weight in kilograms take that
number and you would times it by
somewhere around
25 to 30. it puts you somewhere in like
a two liter range a day
which i know can be scary for some
people they're like i have to go to the
bathroom all the time but spoiler
wearing coved so drink the water and
then you could train your bladder and
you'll be right at your bathroom so it's
totally fine but that helps you with
your skin it helps you with your hair it
helps you with your nails it helps you
with fullness it helps you with
digestion it helps regulate your bowel
movement so water is obviously something
we need to be doing and we need to be
doing more of because people really
don't drink enough water you can get
water from other places so you can get
water from
teas specifically herbal teas you can
get water from coffee but coffee is also
a diuretic so you're going to sort of
eliminate some of that water a little
bit more than you would if you got it
from an herbal tea that doesn't have
that diuretic effect you can get water
from
soups and then most fruits and
vegetables have a really high water
content myth number eight you can't eat
cheese if you're lactose intolerant
this is a pretty dangerous myth because
skipping out on any food group can be
harmful for missing certain nutrients
especially dairy products not all dairy
products contain high amounts of lactose
so people who are lactose intolerant
actually tend to do
well with cheese especially hard cheeses
the soft cheeses tend to have a little
bit more lactose in them yeah like
parmesan cheese for example has no
lactose in it also if you're lactose
intolerant you could train yourself to
tolerate 250
milliliters that's about 8 ounces of
lactose you know the bottom line is you
can eat some cheese even if you're
lactose intolerant myth number nine red
wine is good for your heart okay
actually
this is
the biggest myth of all time
i understand where it must come from
right you know it's made with grapes
grapes have antioxidants and you know
they have flavonoids those tend to help
with the heart so like that's fine and
you know one glass of red wine isn't
going to hurt you but out of like a 250
000 participant study about the effects
of alcohol on the body there are no real
benefits to alcohol alcohol the body
sees as a poison the body has to do a
lot of work and sacrifice a lot of
metabolic processes in order to
metabolize alcohol if you're looking to
support your heart instead of picking up
the closest bottle of wine think about
ways you can incorporate more fiber more
heart healthy fats and of course
increasing your physical activity yeah
you can't increase your physical
activity if you're hungover from the
night before
and dehydrated yeah myth number 10 fresh
produce is always better than frozen
produce fresh produce is definitely
awesome there's nothing wrong with
having fresh produce but not everyone
has access to fresh produce and the cool
thing about frozen produce is that it's
often frozen at peak ripeness so we can
capture all of the vital vitamins and
minerals and nutrients within the
product without having to sacrifice sort
of convenience for being able to store
these things in our freezer myth number
11 you need to drink milk for strong
bones
again this is like
the dairy council i don't know i'm like
afraid they're like gonna come and find
me milk is not necessarily going to help
with strong bones you can get the same
amount of calcium in a stock of broccoli
as a glass of milk the reason why milk
is so called good for our bones is
because as vanessa said the calcium
content but milk is also fortified with
vitamin d which means that it doesn't
naturally contain vitamin d most foods
don't so one of the best ways that you
can get vitamin d is by getting out
there and getting some sun so actually
getting sun might be just as helpful for
strong bones and drinking a glass of
milk if not more helpful myth number 12
probiotics are good for everyone
everybody has probiotics in their gut
already so when we talk about probiotics
in a supplement form some people who
have compromised immunity or who have
certain gut conditions like small
intestine bacterial overgrowth actually
tend to do pretty poorly on probiotics
for the vast majority of the population
probiotics are good for everyone that
doesn't mean you have to take a
supplement you can definitely get it in
food fermented foods like sauerkraut
kimchi myth number 13 an apple a day
keeps the doctor away well kind of i
think this myth needs to be 10 servings
of fruits and vegetables a day keeps the
doctor away making the choice to have an
apple instead of candy is a good choice
and that is certainly going to help
support your health but if the rest of
your diet consists of mostly refined
processed foods that are devoid in
vitamins minerals and fiber then the
doctor is still going to be an important
person in your life myth number 14
cravings mean you're missing something
from your diet there's certainly no
science to say that if you crave x food
then you need to have more of why food
in your diet so cravings can come from a
lot of different places but i've found
that that's mostly from not having
balanced blood sugar and from emotional
psychological reasons you know the
clients come in and they're like i don't
need carbs i'm really good about not
eating carbs but at night i eat an
entire bag of hershey kisses you're like
because you need carbs
eat the carbs so there is a condition
where people deficient in iron they
actually create soil and clay
it's called pica
and so there is something there that
exists around cravings for certain
flavors i don't know why people want to
eat dirt when they're
anemic but that is something that is
real it happens a lot especially with
pregnant women myth 15 everyone should
cut gluten out of their diets
no if it bothers you then cut it out or
if you have celiac disease then cut it
out just the regular person walking down
the street doesn't necessarily need to
cut out gluten right tomorrow everyone's
coming in wanting a gimmick
yeah a lot of people cut out gluten and
they feel better but that's mostly
because they cut out gluten containing
foods which tend to be unhealthy so i
think people tend to confuse the
benefits of cutting out those highly
processed refined carbohydrates with
gluten itself myth number 16
white potatoes are bad for you oh this
myth is so sad
so many people are missing out on
delicious potatoes the potatoes are
actually quite high in potassium and the
skins of potatoes contain a decent
amount of fiber as well white potatoes
also have a good source of vitamin a so
it's good for your eyes the serving size
though is a half cup i think that's the
other problem you think that the because
the potato is purple or you know it's a
sweet potato so it's like more complex
and better for you like but the serving
size really is half of a small one or
half a cup myth 17 activated charcoal is
a superfood what is even a superfood
like everyone talks about these
superfoods this is not a real thing also
charcoal is not a food it doesn't have a
nutritional value it's not something
that we can eat and gain benefits from
it actually passes through our body
completely and if we have it in large
amounts it can be toxic myth number 18
meat is a necessary part of a balanced
diet
this is a controversial one and i love
this topic we do get a lot of nutrients
from meat some of those nutrients we
cannot get from plant-based foods or
it's not as easy to get them from
plant-based foods one of those is b12 so
people who have a mostly plant-based
diet need to supplement with b12 for the
most part that being said we can
absolutely have a plant-based diet and
be incredibly healthy you can also have
a plant-based diet and be unhealthy
you probably shouldn't eat meat
breakfast lunch and dinner you want to
have some plants in there those are all
like sensible things and also if you're
100 vegan don't turn your nose at me
because i'm eating a burger but
everything you eat is from by chloe
because that's also not really healthy
either myth 19 you shouldn't eat after 6
p.m remember oprah in like the 90s had
she lost a bunch of weight and she was
like i don't eat after six and then
everybody was like don't eat after six
you want to give your body time to
digest everything should be metabolized
by the time you go to bed so you can
have a restful sleep there's no hard and
fast rule that you need to stop eating
by 6 p.m it's individualized if all else
fails focus on the basics of eating more
fruits and vegetables eating
meals throughout the day that are
balanced with proteins carbs and healthy
fats and if you can start there that's a
good place it doesn't have to be over
complicated do your research
make sure you understand
you know all the facts presented and
then at the end of the day
just do what's right for you also ask
like professionals not not the internet
guys